on january 15 2008 steve jobs came out
on stage and pulled a legendary product
out of an envelope instantly blowing
everyone's mind and changing the laptop
world forever
and now almost 14 years later apple's
about to do it again with the new m2
macbook air but this time with white
bezels a white keyboard a flat design
and a notch well we've got a lot of
leaks and rumors to unload so let's jump
right into it the story of the m2
macbook air leaks started around six
months ago from john prosser from front
page tech as you can see right here he
revealed exclusive renders of that m2
macbook air just like this you have this
flat design looks incredibly clean these
renders look so good but the thing i
want you guys to look at
is how thin that design is it is just so
incredibly thin you see a usbc port
right there and the entire design is
just slightly larger and as we can see
we have off-white bezels and an
off-white keyboard but recently we just
got some fresh leaks and they are very
controversial and definitely new because
these renders did not show any sort of
notch and now this is what the rumors
are pointing us to look at that the same
notch that i have right here on this 16
inch macbook pro
in white
that just looks so crazy and to me
i'm honestly not even sure about if
they're actually gonna do this or not
with the m2 macbook air because that
honestly looks kind of bad now this
particular leak came from dylan dkt on
twitter as you can see right here here
is his twitter page and he's fairly new
but he's actually pretty reliable he
gave us a lot of little tidbits on what
we should expect from it but i am kind
of worried about a couple of things so
before i break all of this down the
first thing i want to mention is the
design before we get into the m2 chip
and the whole theory about the notch or
no notch the first detail he mentioned
was max safe which we just got on the
new macbook pros so in my opinion it
totally makes sense to add the maxsafe
3rd gen connector onto the macbook air
as well because this year they made it
super slim compared to what it was like
before so it can definitely fit on an
incredibly thin macbook air he also
mentioned that it's going to be getting
a 1080p webcam and i don't know if you
guys have seen the comparisons between
the old one and the new one but there is
definitely a huge difference in terms of
sharpness and it's definitely welcome so
i think that apple is for sure adding
that 1080p webcam now interestingly
dylan says that we're getting usb type-c
ports which i would expect thunderbolt 4
because that's the latest and best port
but if it's going to be a macbook and
maybe it's not tuned for professionals
maybe it won't because if you think
about it the old 12 inch macbook from
2017 it only had a single usb c port not
thunderbolt so what if apple is actually
going to do that same thing so i'm not
exactly sure which way but i really hope
they gave us two thunderbolt 4 ports for
the extra connectivity now moving on we
have the 30 watt power adapter which
totally makes sense and of course he
says no fans which i totally agree with
and if you look at how thin those
renders are from ian's elbow and john
prosser i don't think there's any way
you could fit a fan there and since the
m1 macbook air is fanless and it
performs incredibly well as we've shown
you in all of our reviews i totally
expect apple to not put any sort of fan
on that macbook air and then he mentions
the various color options on that new m2
macbook air similar to the imac 24 inch
and i think that is going to be very
interesting because it feels like apple
is kind of trying to revolutionize the
game by not just sticking to standard
silver space gray or black laptops like
we've been having for a long time but
switching it up and giving people colors
like the airpods max almost like
somebody can match up their entire
ecosystem with their airpods max their
macbook air their ipads having all these
colors it's like they're going for that
new consumer level and that is why dylan
believes we're getting off-white bezels
with an off-white keyboard since that's
what apple did with the 24 inch imac and
it seems to be working because it's
selling well and people are loving it
and i think people are also going to
love the light colored bezels but now
this brings us into the very
controversial bits of info that people
are having a hard time agreeing with for
example dylan says that mini led is
likely now that is interesting because
as we know the new macbook pros have the
mini led promotion displays and dylan
does not believe that the new macbook
air is going to have promotion and i
totally agree there is not going to be
120 hertz promotion on the macbook air
because that's a lower end cheaper
consumer item compared to the pro
macbook pro that deserves promotion
but mini led is still in the air of
course there's not going to be any face
id and no sd card because that's a pro
feature and of course no hdmi and no
tapered design which dylan mentioned and
that makes sense because they're going
all flat with these new macbooks just
like they did with this new macbook pro
and as you can see right here john
prosser from front page tech actually
updated his renders with ian's elbow and
they're showing off the ports that we
should expect and he believes that we
are getting two thunderbolt 4 ports on
each side and here you can see that mac
save 3 is so thin that it still fits
just fine on the m2 macbook air
including the headphone jack just barely
fitting so this gives you a sense of how
insanely thin this macbook is going to
be and this is why i believe it's going
to disrupt the entire laptop industry
because this is just going to blow
people's minds having such a thin device
like an as thin as an ipad pro it's just
gonna be crazy but this right here is
what is very controversial look at that
notch i've gotta say that's pretty ugly
i'm just having a hard time believing
that apple is gonna give a notch to the
macbook air
with white bezels because as you can see
i just went into full screen mode and
the entire notch on this macbook pro
just disappeared because the notch is
black
and the screen is black now imagine if
you're on this m2 macbook air and the
rest of that goes black but you
literally still see a light colored
notch right there i just can't see it
working i just i'm finding it hard to
believe that apple would actually do
this now of course one option is just to
cut a line here and then literally
display the light colored bezel on the
display to make it seamless and make it
look like it's a fully squared display
white colored without the notch but
you're gonna be running into issues with
white balance and everything else so i
don't think apple is gonna go that route
however we got a bombshell leak from
leaks apple pro who says he has an
exclusive leak of the actual cad files
for the m2 macbook air and as you can
see here they are everything looks
normal you have your headphone jack your
thunderbolt 4 part right there same
thing right here than about four max a3
so this looks like it could actually be
official cad files but he gave us a very
very interesting tidbit he says that
there will not be a notch and based on
his renders and his cad files he was
able to create this render right here
and as you can see there is no notch on
this m2 macbook air now what really got
me thinking is the original reasoning
for the notch for the macbook pro now
apple says they were able to basically
thin down the bezels like crazy as you
can see right here incredibly thin
bezels by adding that notch in so my
thought is what if apple is not going to
give us those crazy thin bezels on the
m2 macbook air and they're going to give
us the thicker bezels and basically kind
of force us to spend more money if we
want super thin bezels by only going for
the macbook pro so essentially the
cheaper m2 macbook air would still stick
to the thick bezels and therefore they
would be able to kind of redesign that
camera and stick it up there into the
bezel and not have any notch at all and
in my opinion if apple is gonna go for
light-colored keyboard and light-colored
bezels this makes the absolute most
sense right here but if by any chance we
do get a notch which i honestly don't
think we're gonna get i don't think that
it's gonna look this bad because as you
can see there's like this dark line
going around this notch to kind of make
it more
visible i don't think it's gonna be
anything like that i think it's gonna be
more seamless and it's gonna blend
better into the wallpaper so it's not
going to look this bad now moving on to
the next bit of info that dylan gave us
he says that there's a chance that this
laptop might not actually be the macbook
air it could be just straight macbook
like we had with the 12-inch macbook
that was totally discontinued and it
doesn't exist right now so what if apple
is going to revive the macbook as this
new laptop and this might actually make
sense to me because this new potential
macbook could totally replace the lower
end 13-inch macbook pro because apple
could be basically forcing us to pay 2
000
for the newer more expensive high
performance macbook pro and they could
just give us a macbook for the middle
ground in between the macbook air the
macbook and the macbook pro so
essentially it's already been in the
leaks that the m1 macbook air is gonna
stick around at the same thousand dollar
price point for maybe at least another
year and then this thing's going to come
in to fill in a gap and that's what i
think is going to happen so i think
there is a good chance that apple could
just straight up call it a macbook and
now of course everybody's talking about
the m2 macbook air which points to the
m2 chip and i know a lot of you guys
have questions about that so let's get
right into it and answer them this
brings us to a report from mark german
from last year in january saying that
it's going to be getting a next-gen chip
so what that means is that you could
basically look at the m1 chip which is
an eight core and then basically the
next generation kind of like apple goes
from a11 to a12 a13 a14 chip they're
gonna do the same thing with the m1
basically just upgraded with new
technology now what's interesting here
is that mark german mentioned that it's
gonna be getting two usbc ports he also
did not mention thunderbolt so this
might actually mean that we're only
getting usbc for i guess the regular
average consumers and before we jump
into the core count mark german actually
mentioned that it's gonna be getting two
usbc ports not thunderbolt which is very
interesting and it's gonna be releasing
as early as the second half of 2021
which we know is not happening this year
it definitely got delayed but he
mentioned that apple considered a 15
inch version of the macbook air but they
completely scrapped it so i know a lot
of people are still wondering if we're
getting a 15-inch but it looks like we
are not getting it it's still sticking
to 13 inches according to mark germain
and as far as the m2 chip dylan jkt also
believes we're getting the m2 within the
first half of 2022 and it's gonna debut
with the new colorful macbook now as far
as the core counts mark grumman gave us
some info back in may saying that the m2
is gonna have the same eight core cpu so
that's four performance cores and four
efficiency cores but in terms of the
graphics it's now going to be basically
up to 10 cores for the gpu but you could
get 9 on the base model which he
believes it's still going to be binned
so you're going to be able to save some
money with the bend 9 core gpu instead
of the full 10. but the big question we
have to answer is what is it going to be
based on because a lot of people were
thinking it could be based on the three
nanometer technology from tsmc but now
it looks like that has been delayed so
digit times has reported that it's going
to be based on the four nanometer tech
however they came back with an update
saying that the n4p process is actually
tsmc's third major advancement of the
five nanometer family so it's not even
going to go down to four nanometers it's
going to be sticking to five nanometers
but delivering an 11
performance boost so that is very
interesting because a lot of people
thought that four nanometer tech was
ready but it looks like it might not be
due to this report now there is actually
a lot to break down here because it's
saying it's 11 boost over n5 and only 6
over n4 now what that means is that the
original n5 tech is actually the a14
chip and the m1 so the m1 macbook air so
it's going to give an 11 boost basically
with the same clock speeds over the m1
but the n4 technology is actually the
second gen 5 nanometer which is the a15
chip so that's very interesting but
what's really going to matter is this
right here n4p will deliver a 22
improvement in power efficiency as well
as a six percent improvement in
transistor density so basically this is
going to mean a lot of things for the
battery life you're going to get much
better battery life and it seems like
the whole design is going to run cooler
so of course they can make it thinner
without sacrificing heat or anything
like that and now the last thing we've
got to discuss is the release date
because that's obviously what all of us
want to know and that brings us back to
a report from inquo on august 10th and
he was claiming that a new redesigned
macbook air with mini led so he believes
it will get mini led and color options
is launching in mid
2022 now what mid meant to me was wwdc
because that's right in the middle in
june so it seems like that's the perfect
event for apple to unveil or reveal this
new macbook air because it's going to be
the two-year anniversary ever since
apple basically announced the apple
silicon transition now however ming chi
quo recently came out and he now says
that it's gonna enter mass production in
the third quarter of 2022
so that basically means that apple is
again delaying it so they're not going
to be even beginning the production
until the third quarter so that makes a
wwc reveal unlikely so that basically
means that a reveal at wwc is not likely
and it's gonna take until october or
november for apple to reveal the new
macbook air now in my opinion what this
points to is apple starting a tick tock
cycle so for example one year they
reveal the lower end products like the
macbook air and then another year they
reveal the higher end products like the
macbook pro so that's basically two
years in between the macbook pros
releasing and getting updated and that's
why i believe it's gonna be until 2023
until the new macbook pro gets updated
again so it's very interesting that it
seems like apple is going this route but
this is definitely going to be exciting
but with all that said and out of the
way let me just wrap up exactly what i
think this m2 macbook air is going to
look like and be like i feel like the
design is going to be exactly like you
see right here just basically identical
in terms of the white keyboard just like
we have on the external keyboards with
the imacs currently like the 24 inch
imac and i also think that the design
from the side is gonna look almost
identical just like this render from
ian's elbow and john prosser however it
might be just slightly thicker maybe
because it seems like there's just not
enough room here especially with that
headphone jack but i guess we will see
and then in my opinion i do not think
we're gonna be getting a notch like that
i think apple is just gonna give us
thicker bezels and somehow find a way to
bring that webcam a little bit higher so
that it basically is going to end up
looking like this except i don't think
we're going to have rounded corners on
the bottom maybe only on the top but i
guess we will see so with that said
hopefully you enjoyed this video on the
leaks and rumors on the m2 macbook air
and if you did definitely click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]